[Music]
jason joins us in tallahassee florida
jason welcome to the ramsay show
hey george and dr john thanks for taking
my call absolutely how can we help
okay so
uh my wife and i have 13 years we had
we had three houses together we each had
one before we met
and we bought one together
we just sold the one that we bought
together and we made a handsome profit
and i'm kind of wondering what to do
with that cash and here's kind of the
conundrum
um
my house is paid for her house is not
and her ex-husband is responsible for
paying her note by their divorce
agreement
so she wants to just keep all this money
in savings and i'm thinking there's got
to be something better we can do with it
how long have you been married
13 years 13 years
i don't hear a lot of couples who've
been married 13 years
still referring to her house in my house
tell me how that works i mean we've
never we've never consolidated we i
owned my house outright before we met
and she was supposed to own her house
outright when she got divorced
and we've just left them in each of our
names i actually live at her house i
rent my house out
and all of our
all of our bank accounts are joint the
only thing that's not joint is
the titles on these houses
would it change your psychology in your
home if you referred to these homes as
y'all's homes and suddenly you've got
another guy you know what i mean
we
we do and and i actually suggested that
we just pay hers off
um i mean we've got you know 200k
sitting in the bank right now is
no no is her ex-husband still living in
it
oh no he's got his own place
but he's paying the mortgage as part of
the divorce agreement
yeah she was supposed to get the house
outright and he's not on the dave's plan
of paying it off in any big hurry
and you guys are living she wants to
we're living there she wants to let him
keep paying it as long as he will but
he's sort of running a failing business
dude sell the house and get out of that
mess this feels like a weird situation
the ex-husband is getting paid
for where you're living
yeah the house is in her name
sell it sell it in her name
but there's still a note on it sell it
get out of the mess get her ex-husband
stop paying your rent
get out of it yeah i mean like you got
to change your like your house and my
house and then our house bro you've got
three houses y'all are married for 13
years you oh your family has three
houses start using that language
and then well two at this point okay
yeah there you go you just sold one so
i'm not gonna live in a house her
husband out of it i could get her
husband out of it by just paying it off
and her take on it is that lets him off
the hook for what she is owed
and she's playing a 13-year game of
vengeance and
all she's doing is killing herself
slowly
i i don't care what you got to do man
get that guy out of your life you got to
pay the house off sell the house and
move into the other house sell that
house and take all that cash and buy
y'all a house together that's new for
whatever you got to do man get that guy
out of your life
what's the what's left on the market on
that
good what's left on the mortgage
108 and you have 200 in the
bank correct which means if you paid it
off today you'd have 92 000 does that
include your emergency fund and
everything
uh no i've still got an extra emergency
fund over that i'm fully invested in my
traditional ira don't have a roth i need
to do that
well what i would do
like john's saying if you pay that thing
off you've got 92 sitting in the bank
that you can do anything with and you
have a paid for house you don't have a
payment in the world then you can decide
hey do we want to get into more real
estate do we want to be in the real
estate business and get some more
properties what do we want to do with
this money and you could max out your
retirement accounts have you ever had
cancer
no
okay
you do you have a
cancer and you can solve that cancer
with a hundred thousand dollars
if i'm you in your financial situation i
would do that for the days over
and that man's name would be voldemort
in my home and we would just be done
saying it jason what happens if he can't
pay the mortgage he said he has a
failing business let's say he can't make
the payment doesn't that put you guys at
risk
that's the point we have enough cash to
but she wants it to just sit in a
savings account just in case he can't
pay she wants to punish him get him out
of your lives let him go let him go be
free
he hey you know what he drug it out for
13 years he won golf clap
congratulations man you beat the system
high five way to go
we're rich we got lots of money we're
baby steps millionaires and i'm cutting
my wife's ex-husband out of our life
forever i'm gonna live in my house that
doesn't even have a note on it and my ex
my wife's ex-husband's no longer gonna
pay my mortgage that's the move thanks
for the college cancer out interesting
situation